[Music]
chuck do you want to go on a space
voyage that lasts longer than your own
life
um yeah let me think about that
sorry stupid question
all right i'm guessing the answer is no
oh yeah that's a very very good guess
okay because we can travel to the moon
that's like three days
mars is nine months um some other
planets
a year two years five years and we could
probably get to the outer solar system
in ten years that's within a human life
expectancy
right all right now there is a rule in
science that never engage in an
experiment where you don't get the
results until
after you're dead all right that doesn't
it's not good for your career
so so you want stuff to happen in
between but
here's my point until we discover
wormholes or warp drives or something
that could greatly shorten the time it
takes to travel the vast
distances of interstellar space
journeys across the galaxy will be
hopeless unless
we take on a different understanding of
space travel and say
here's what we're going to do let's put
astronauts on board that no they will
not be alive when they arrive at their
destination
wow but those astronauts will have to be
fertile
so that they then mate have babies
raise the babies they die now the babies
are home
the the the next generation is at the
helm of the ship
and then they have babies and this
continues so there's a word for this
we've already thought this through
they're called generational ships
oh i thought it was called sex
it's called generational ships
generational ships
you'd have to control it because you
don't want to make too many people you
need the right number of people plus you
have to train them
or you have to educate them because you
need your engineers and your
medical doctors and your you know your
your
your space cadets whatever so so
so this is the it's called a
generational ship
and it has interesting ethical questions
right
right to bring an entire generation
of humans into the world
whose only mission is to bring another
generation into the world
with a goal that they will never see
well
in a way neil that is
kind of the spaceship that we're on
right now
it's just a microcosm of that chuck
getting philosophically deep so you're
saying we already
have a generation that we birth right
and we train them to try to figure stuff
out and then we die off and we will
never know where that ends
absolutely and we're all just doing that
on a giant rock that's floating through
space on a
on a destination to who knows where
actually it's not even just just going
around
[Laughter]
[Music]
i think that that's actually you know
kind of noble if somebody were to
volunteer and go
and take on that task of exploration for
the sake
of um you know the getting to a place
and finding out
that but would you be able yes you would
at some point be able to transmit your
findings back to earth
right by the speed of light that is
where the light but but here's a here's
an interesting question
would you ever plan to come back to
earth
because you'll probably lose all of your
immunities
that you have if you grow up on earth
you know if you go up on earth you're
exposed to
colds as a kid and you're right you know
and then you build your immune system
and then as adults you're pretty hardy
if you if you don't have that normal
earth
baptism to germs and returning
could be lethal absolutely yeah and we
think we have it bad now with
nut allergies
like you got kids now just like i wish i
knew what peanut butter jelly tastes
like
i i can't eat peanut butter i will die
but let me tell you something i have
three children and two of them can't eat
peanut butter they're like oh god
oh you're trying to kill me dad you're
trying to kill me so these kids on this
spaceship
that's going to be the worst
wow
all right so of course the spaceship
would have to have a way
to create energy reserves in the form of
food
for people to eat right okay so they
have to have an
energy source convertible into food you
have a nuclear energy but you can't eat
nuclear energy
okay but we eat plants and animals and
and other things and so
so they have to figure that out on the
generational chip that's all i'm saying
most of it might have to be food for
three generations of people
right that's a lot that is that that's a
lot
um so but or what you could do
before you leave earth you get a full
supply
of all viruses and bacteria that afflict
people
and then every now and then you brush it
on everybody on the
on the ship
okay like you're basting a turkey come
over here junior you know
get your streptococcus right now exactly
time for you to have a little flu
influenza here you go time for your
influenza buddy
right right and that way they keep up
with the earth
that's all that's that you know what
that that would be kind of
that that would make sense you know we
didn't really
catch diseases before we had city living
right i mean think about it you have a
little community that never saw any
other community had your one little farm
that's all they did and any disease that
ever existed that they would have
is already there and they've already got
community we called them native
americans you know they already had
dairy immunity to their own dam diseases
right right
so once you have these enclaves then
they're sort of insulated unless
a traveler comes to town so maybe that
fear of travelers
has some merit historically when you
think about it that makes sense they
could be bringing disease and you've
never met you don't know them from
anybody
right you don't know who their pappy is
you don't know let's see now on our
generational ship
i'd rather think of it in the marvel
universe way
is that something goes wrong with the
ship's shield
and a radiation accident turns them all
into uh super beings they at some point
return
to earth and we don't recognize them and
they come back
as conquerors so they're ow wow
they're our children they're our
children but they
come back and they're just like so they
fly too
close to a supernova right and the
radiation field
messes with your dna right and they have
x-men type powers or you go x-men or
marvel either the universe will
accommodate this and then they come back
and we find out
they are us they are us except that they
came back
this is like planet of the apes but in
another kind of dimension
oh that's true right because they return
to earth that's right
yeah and then they come back and they go
they didn't blow it up
they didn't
damn it the hell they did damn it's
still here it's still here
[Laughter]
you got to see the movie planet of the
18th 1968 or whatever
if you haven't seen that classic that's
that's canon that's
canon all right so but his there's one
thing i haven't told you about
okay okay here it is
you can ask the question by the way we
did a whole explainer video
on minimizing the weight of your payload
how important that is when you're
traveling okay absolutely so
let's ask the question uh if this is a
generational ship
that means you're making babies okay so
could you instead of having women carry
the baby to term you know we fertilize
embryos in a test tube why not carry
them to term in some kind of incubating
box okay oh yeah
okay so then nobody has to carry babies
and everybody okay but
you also so i don't know if you've seen
this show maybe a lot of people haven't
because i think it's kind of new
ridley scott who i love his sci-fi
approach to filmmaking
uh because he often keeps it a little
more real
he has a new show out called it's on hbo
max it's called raised by wolves
and it's exactly what you just explained
oh
so instead of a box it's an android
okay the android is the box
and the android is responsible
for reproduction for reproduction but so
what happens is
the further don't give it away oh okay
give it away and it's it's actually
really good and so okay
okay i'm psyched about it and you're
right i was about to spoil
everything no no but here's the question
that you'd have to ask
all right if you know what is the box
way
that does this right if the box weighs
more than just pick
pick a 130 pounds if it weighs more than
about 130 pounds
then it's cheaper in terms of payload
right to just have farms of women making
babies than farms of these boxes
okay but that's a little creepy because
it's reminiscent of that show that got
so popular
the handmaidens tale okay where the the
remaining
uh population of fertile women are
making all the babies for this
so that's a little weird okay so here it
is
the box while it's pregnant
is still only a box whereas the woman
while she's pregnant
is still the engineer or the medical
doctor
or the flight captain so
so the value of a payload is not just
what does it weigh
but what else is it contributing to the
rest of the
of the of the vessel so i think what you
just proved here
is that women are far more valuable than
men
basically that's why men are afraid of
them because they could do everything we
could do
and make babies so
anyhow so just something to think about
on generational ships i mean there's a
lot more than what we just discussed
but it's an interesting dilemma that we
have in the absence of warp drives
so there but i'd like your your marvel
universe twist on it they come back and
they become our overlords
and we had begat them 30 generations ago
there you go wow yeah chuck we got to
end it there
all right man hi dude great that was
another explainer video
awesome there's no end of these chuck i
just want you know i'll be up in your
face all the time doing this i'm
i'm i am just my face will be here
okay
right can be up in your face if your
face isn't there thank you for that
logical
reasoning this has been star talk
explainer always great to have chuck
i'm neil degrasse tyson i'm getting you
to keep looking
you